I'm interested in the social potential
for art rather rather than the
valorisation of some form of expression
his recognizable symbols figures
recognizable figures and images and this
this is an invitation into a shared
space within the collective imaginary
it's not just a celebration of pop
culture the this common ground has been
created so that we have a place to me
and at this place there's also
uncertainty so while the objects are
immediately accessible they're also sort
of promiscuous and ambiguous in their
meaning the certainty of the reference
is a laced with a kind of doubt and I
believe this experience to be productive
in the sense that it generates new
possibilities the potential for new new
realities within a context of open an
undetermined social exchange that we
would call the gallery or some other
context what you refer to as symbols of
community are not actually symbols I
don't think in my work symbol implies a
certain level of detachment but the
layer of illusion in my work is always
in a relationship with the material
itself and with the form of the object
and inseparable from it I think that
what I think of the works is literally
sites of human activity that have the
memory of past forms of socialization
embedded within them it's a way of
connecting real places of human to human
experience between the past the present
and the future
you